visibility's dance a 15 or 20 Lisa's
this if a man says lying smile and when
you dress or just hit hunky Dan and
white until we've brought a good
clearance in the whether it's you could
move will touch base in sorrow all right
on Tom Arnold I'm a field trainer with
Antarctica New Zealand I spend most
summer seasons down in Antarctica and
doing field safety for the science
events that come down there knowing that
it's it's my responsibility to make sure
that everybody can get back to Scott Bay
safely is huge huge deal and we believe
this to be probably the most dangerous
area the challenge is to betray to
people how difficult it is to work down
in that environment walking on the sea
ice - crossing professed terrain -
working on the side of Mount Erebus the
average person needs to sort of be aware
of the changes that are happening down
there it's a very isolated continent and
and it's very hard to get to and so the
science research that's coming out of
there is really important for the future
of the the climates all over the world
especially in the northern hemisphere
what a small fish in there in the grand
scheme of things and mother nature
really has control here yeah the Adelie
penguins are probably my favourite down
there and lots of people like the
Empress because of that there are really
beautiful quite large birds but the
Adela's have got personality they run
around with these big sort of smiles on
their face don't come for the home for
me it's coffee good coffee down there so
no matter where we go we'll always take
a a French press or a stovetop expresso
maker with us so we can enjoy a good
coffee first thing in the morning